hace ya varios vídeos e introduje la
idea de lo que es una serie de furia en
donde tomamos una función periódica
verdad como en el ejemplo que tenemos
aquí que es una onda cuadrada verdad y
la podemos representar como la suma de
senos y cosenos con pesos verdad y luego
tomamos todo un intermedio bastante
largo para poder prepararnos con las
bases matemáticas en donde tomábamos
integrales de senos y cosenos verdad
combinaciones de ellos sobre el periodo
de esta función verdad que en este caso
es de periodo 2 p
verdad la función periódica y obtuvimos
todas estas propiedades ahora vamos a
beneficiarnos de todas estas propiedades
desde estas propiedades y en realidad lo
que vamos a hacer es tratar de hallar
fórmulas para los coeficientes de furia
de nuestra función muy bien entonces
esto espero que sea bastante directo
aplicando lo que ya hemos visto en los
vídeos anteriores y luego lo vamos a
aplicar a la onda cuadrada para que se
para que se vea que en realidad puede
ser bastante sí
cómo hacerlo así que aquí abajo he
reescrito la digamos la expresión en
serie de furia de verdad en una función
efe dt con periodo 2 y vamos a utilizar
las propiedades anteriores para poder
calcular quiénes son nuestros
coeficientes muy bien y en este vídeo
sólo vamos a tratar de hallar a 0 que es
el primer término el término constante y
en los próximos vídeos hallaremos a n
para en arbitraria y también b n quizás
en vídeos separados ahora para poder
hallar a 0 tomaremos lo que es la
integral desde 0 a 2 pide nuestra
función muy bien entonces ese será el
primer paso vamos a tomar la integral de
0 a 2 piden nuestra función con respecto
a t verdad y como esto es una igualdad
esto será lo mismo a tomar la integral
de 0 a 2 pi de toda esta expresión
verdad que esto da una
una suma infinita de distintos términos
y vamos a integrarlo con respecto a te
verdad entonces en realidad como tenemos
la integral de una de un montón de sumas
verdad de distintos términos esto será
igual a la integral o más bien a la suma
de todas las integrales duraban entonces
déjenme quitar esto y quitar esto y esto
en realidad va a ser la integral de este
término con respecto a t la integral de
este término con respecto a t la
integral de este término con respecto a
t entonces podrás darte cuenta que esto
ya se volvió algo muy monótono la
integral de 0 a 2 p con respecto a t la
integral de 0 a 2 pi con respecto a t la
integral de 0 a 2 pi con respecto a t y
así sucesivamente verdad entonces ahora
lo que podemos observar de cada una de
estas integrales es que estas constantes
verdad estas constantes como están
multiplicando
la función pueden salir hacia afuera de
las integrales y ésta puede salirse para
acá por ejemplo de este lado esta puede
salirse esta puede salirse de la
integral verdad y ese es un siguiente
paso que podemos hacer para tratar de
simplificar todo esto verdad y en
realidad si nos damos cuenta en estos
términos que tenemos aquí abajo sólo nos
quedan integrales de senos y cosenos
verdad de hecho escogen la integral de
cocina integral de ese 9 integral de
coseno de 2 t integral de cocina de nt
integral de seno
tnt y de hecho como podrás darte cuenta
ya vimos en vídeos anteriores que la
integral del seno de múltiplos de t y la
integral del coseno de múltiplos de t
son 0 para cualquier m entero en el caso
del seno y vale 0 para cualquier m
entero no nulo en el caso del coseno
verdad
justamente los casos que tenemos aquí
abajo muy bien entonces esta integral
vale 0 este integral vale 0 está también
vale 0
vale 0 vale 0 todas estas integrales que
tenemos aquí valen 0 verdad entonces con
qué nos vamos a quedar pues simplemente
nos quedamos con esta integral que
tenemos acá arriba y de hecho quizás
debería irla simplificando esta integral
cuanto vale bueno pues tendremos que
hacer o también se puede salir de la
integral verdad también puede salir de
la integral y entonces tendríamos a sub
zero verdad por la integral de cero a
dos pi de uno o podríamos simplemente
dejarlo como la integral de t verdad y
esto quien sería pues esto sería a cero
por la anti derivada de uno que sería t
aquí tendríamos t evaluada de 0 a 2 pi y
esto es simplemente a 0 que multiplica a
2 -0 verdad y por supuesto esto
simplemente lo podemos dejar como 2 pi
entonces vamos a dejarlo esto como a 0
por 2 pi muy bien y finalmente ahora
podemos calcular quién es acero verdad
porque regresamos a nuestra expresión
original y lo que tenemos es la integral
de 0 a 2 pi de nuestra función
efe de james y estamos integrando con
respecto a t verdad es lo que tenemos
del lado izquierdo y del lado derecho
tenemos esta integral que ya calculamos
que es a 0 a 0 a 0 x 2 x 2
entonces despejamos a sub zero
simplemente dividimos de ambos lados
entre 2 pi y tenemos que hacer o es
igual a 1 entre 2
1 / 2 p por la integral de 0 a 2 pi de
nuestra función
efe dt y estamos integrando por supuesto
con respecto a t y esto es bastante
bastante interesante porque lo que
nosotros tenemos del lado derecho es
justamente el valor promedio de nuestra
función en el periodo o en la longitud
de digamos en el intervalo 02 de verdad
entonces esto será el valor promedio el
valor promedio de nuestra función
efe te voy a ponerlo bien de la función
efe dt en el intervalo 0,2 bien esa es
una de las interpretaciones de acero y
espero que esto sea bastante intuitivo
porque si regresamos a nuestra imagen
que teníamos originalmente digamos y
regresamos a esta imagen de aquí
nosotros sabemos que el seno y el coseno
verdad en realidad son funciones que
están oscilando entre
1 y 1 así que por ejemplo aquí a 0
inicialmente lo que hace es desplazar
nuestra función verdad lo que hace es
desplazar la función y ahora suena
bastante intuitivo que queramos
desplazar nuestra función hacia el valor
promedio de nuestra función verdad
entonces por ejemplo más o menos aquí se
vería el valor promedio de la onda
cuadrada verdad entonces ahora queremos
que la función esté oscilando alrededor
del valor promedio y esta es la
interpretación de azul cero es el valor
promedio de nuestra función